[Musik]
ich habe lowjo keine Ahnung wie ich das
Video hier heute beginnen soll was ich
sagen soll und ich weiß auch gar nicht
warum ich das nicht weiß aber ich fühle
mich richtig gut und ich habe richtig
Bock und ich bin richtig hyped auf
dieses Projekt was wir hier heute
starten werden denn vor fast zwei Jahren
habe ich Minecraft ein Luca Staffel 1
gestartet was ein komplett normales
Standard survival Singleplayer Let's
Play war und heute darf ich euch
willkommen heißen zu einem neuen Projekt
auf meinem Kanal und zwar Skyblock mit
Luca also mir
ich bin hier gemacht erstmal ein Orangen
Tee
[Musik]
den werde ich mir nie wieder machen
allerdings würde ich sagen klicken wir
jetzt hier einfach mal auf die Map drauf
und bewegen uns das allererste Mal in
den Ort rein
[Musik]
sach
dabei bin ich blöd habe ich ein
Sehfehler oder sind ja auch noch andere
Inseln gerade ich als Kranker Minecraft
og Player der das Spiel ja wirklich
schon vor 11 Jahren angefangen hat zu
zocken kann euch nur sagen dass es
Skyblock was ich kenne
es wird echt immer besser
auch noch Regen hier jetzt oder
wir können direkt aufhören wir können
direkt das Projekt beenden kommen der
Tee schmeckt scheiße ich spawne hier
alles wieder Quatsch hier aber gut
Freunde ich würde sagen wir lassen uns
davon nicht unterkriegen und versuchen
das Beste raus zu machen erstmal für
euch zur Erklärung falls ihr Minecraft
Skyblock nicht kennen solltet das hier
ist alles was es gibt in dieser Welt
diese Insel auf der wir uns gerade
befinden und diese paar anderen Inseln
die wir im Laufe dieses Projektes
erkunden werden
wir haben zwei Regeln Regel Nummer eins
ist man darf nicht absichtlich von
dieser Insel hier runter springen wenn
man beispielsweise sein Leben relativ
gering hat und das absichtlich dadurch
regenerieren will das darf man nicht das
ist verboten das werden wir auch nicht
tun das wohin war leider aus Versehen
weil ich einfach dumm bin und Regel
Nummer zwei von zwei ist dass wir
mindestens auf Stufe leicht spielen
sollten also einfach wir spielen
allerdings auf normal weil ihr wisst ich
bin ein Profi da ich euch die zwei
Regeln dieses Projekt jetzt vorgestellt
habe sage ich euch jetzt was das Ziel
des Spiels hier ist wir haben eine 60
challenges die wir erfüllen müssen das
sind teils banale Sachen wie
beispielsweise ein Bett bauen oder 64
Holz haben oder ein Haus bauen
allerdings sind das auch teilweise echt
schwierige Sachen wie beispielsweise ein
höllenportal erstellen oder eine
goldfarm eine Monster fahr mit einem
Spawner quasi machen oder generell das
Spiel schlussendlich beenden indem man
in das Ende geht und den Enderdrachen
besiegt
diese 60 challenges das habe ich mir als
Aufgabe gestellt möchte ich bis zum
Jahresende abgeschlossen haben
ich weiß nicht ob ich das hinkriegen
werde aber wir versuchen es mal und
deswegen verlieren wir auch gar nicht
lange Zeit und öffnen
[Musik]
also ich will jetzt wieder nicht wie so
ein alter Sack klingen aber das Skyblock
was ich gespielt habe beinhaltete nur
Eis und ein lavaimer also sagt mir gern
mal in unten in den Kommentaren was ich
mit einer verdammten meeresgurke
leuchtbären Zuckerrohr und 10 Obsidian
anstellen soll ich würde allerdings
sagen ich nehme erstmal die Dinge mit
denen ich vertraut bin hier raus und
zwar das Eis und den lavaimer denn wir
müssen jetzt einen Cobblestone also
bruchsteingenerator bauen
ich habe keine Ahnung mehr wie das geht
ich weiß nur dass wir den Lava Eimer
nicht zu nah hier an den Baum setzen
sollten weil er dann Feuer fangen könnte
und im besten Fall auch nicht zu nah an
die Kiste deswegen würde ich direkt hier
mal alles aus der Kiste rausnehmen die
Kiste ganz vorsichtig abbauen ich hoffe
jetzt nur die fällt nicht runter ne zack
okay die haben wir und dann stellen wir
die Kiste einfach mal hier an die Seite
die Blume baue ich mir auch ganz kurz ab
zack die haben wir auch wir müssen
wirklich vorsichtig vorgehen ne mit
allen Materialien mit allem was wir
haben ich will nicht mal Gras gerade
abbauen weil wir eventuell mit
lichtlevel warten könnten dass das
weiter wächst und dass wir noch eine
größere Chance haben hier seeds also
Samen für Weizen rauszukriegen was auch
eine Aufgabe ist und zwar eine
Weizenfarm zu erstellen weil wir erstmal
nur damit wirklich essen können wir
können allerdings eh nicht groß sprinten
und dementsprechend hungerkeulen unten
rechts im Inventar verlieren weil wir
nur auf keine Ahnung 15 Blöcken hier
unterwegs sind aber gut ich laber zu
viel ich das schon wieder viel zu viel
Zeit wir packen hier erstmal alles rein
was ich gerade erstmal nicht benötige
deswegen haben wir hier jetzt Platz für
einen bruchstein-generator hier drunter
haben wir auf jeden Fall auch noch Erde
das hier bei euch auch mal ganz kurz ab
das Gras muss jetzt leider zerstören
vielleicht nee kommt nichts raus und äh
dem Bau ich auch noch ab und das müssen
wir jetzt glaube ich auch zerstören also
hier auch noch mal drauf kommt auch
keine Samen raus war gut okay das hier
auf jeden Fall hier rein und jetzt
müssen wir hier ein Loch graben glaube
ich ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich so
funktioniert hier den
Eisblock drauf und jetzt erstmal warten
dass der zu Wasser wird
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht ob das nicht gleich
schief gehen wird
also ich weiß nicht ob ich hier komplett
verloren bin gerade es hat übrigens
gerade aufgehört zu regnet deswegen
dachte ich ich mache mal kurz weiter
mich das zu zeigen
aber der Eisblock wurde tatsächlich in
den letzten fünf Minuten nicht
umgewandelt in einen wasserblock
ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt ich setze mal
hier die Erde hin noch mal und setzt sie
neben ein Lava einmal vielleicht in der
Lava einmal so nah dran ist
checkt der Eisblock oh es wird warm ich
Schmelz mal lieber
der Profi und jetzt muss ich ganz
vorsichtig vorgehen denn ich muss den
Lava einmal nehmen diesen Erdblock
abbauen und diesen Erdblock abbauen und
jetzt diesen AdBlock wieder hinsetzen so
dass das Wasser direkt hier runter geht
und ich hier vorne die Lava hinsetzen
kann
so dass hoffentlich hier Bruchsteine
generiert werden denn wenn ich
irgendetwas falsch mache kommt hier
Obsidian und wir haben für das komplette
Projekt verkackt
3 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da sag noch einer hey hier Luca keine
Ahnung von Minecraft ey schau mal hier
so einfach geht das
ja wir bauen wir das jetzt ab
wir brauchen natürlich eine Spitzhacke
und müssen dementsprechend diesen Baum
hier Abfällen von daher packe ich jetzt
erstmal alles Unnötige hier rein falls
wir runterfallen dass wir auf jeden Fall
noch ein paar Sachen haben die erdblöcke
behalte ich erstmal denn die benötige
ich um die im besten Falle hier so jetzt
muss ich ganz vorsichtig sein
[Musik]
die benötige ich um das zu machen was
ihr gerade schon gesehen habt
wir müssen tatsächlich hier vorsichtig
sein dass wir auch kein einzigen
Holzding verschwenden und erst recht
kein einzigen Setzling verschwenden von
den Blättern hier oben damit wir neue
Bäume pflanzen können also der Holzblock
bitte zu mir fallen sehr gut haben wir
schon zwei Stück das hier ist der dritte
und den Rest lasse ich erstmal dran weil
ich hoffe
dass die Blätter so erstmal nicht die
spawnen und wir uns aus drei Stück
zumindest schon mal das craften können
was wir als erstes benötigen nämlich
eine Werkbank und auf jeden Fall auch
Stöcker oh mein Gott
ich habe ein bisschen Schiss
dass der hier meinen Gras anzündet keine
Weizen Setzlinge keine Samen keine Samen
es ist 900 November deswegen habe ich
auch leider keine Samen hierfür das
Projekt wir haben nur noch eins zwei
drei vier sechs von diesen Gras Dingern
wenigstens kann da vorne nichts mehr
abbrennen ich pack den Mohn hier rein
und äh würde jetzt einfach mal die
Werkbank hier hinsetzen die jetzt mit
unserem Holz eine
holzspitzhacke machen mit der wir uns
müssen wir hier auch erstmal ganz
vorsichtig sein ne der darf nicht
runterfallen okay
ähm wir bauen jetzt hier den ersten
Bruchstein ab sehr gut sehr stabil sehr
stabil und noch ein
sehr stark sehr stark sehr stark und
noch einen dritten erstmal boah sehr
sehr wild denn die setzt sich jetzt
erstmal hier außenrum so dass mir hier
nichts passieren kann und wir auch
generell
hier auch Bruchsteine drumherum setzen
aber das mache ich erstmal noch nicht
weil ich ein bisschen Schiss habe dass
die Lava mir hier alles mögliche so ein
bisschen abbrennt also ich gönne mir
noch ein paar mehr um mir daraus gleich
die Dings zu machen
die
Bruchstein Stufen damit wir ein bisschen
Bruchsteine sparen können und die dann
wiederum der ist gerade verbrannt in der
Lava und die bruchsteinstufen dann
wiederum hier vorne drumherum zu machen
um das alles noch so ein bisschen zu
erweitern wodurch wir einerseits unsere
Insel erweitern allerdings auch
ein bisschen mehr Platz lassen für die
Setzlinge boah ich habe immer Schiss
wenn ich über diesem Abgrund stehe ne
vielleicht sollte ich auch mal lieber
bevor ich runterfallen alles hier
reinpacken was ich gerade nicht benötige
so weil Cobblestone kann ich mir immer
wiederholen ähm wir müssen tatsächlich
auf jeden einzelnen Setting achten
deswegen würde ich auch am liebsten noch
einen weitergehen und dementsprechend
noch mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
Bruchsteine abbauen
ich bin auf 180 ich merke auch wirklich
wie mein Herz ne wenn ich hier gerade
eine Apple watch oder irgendwie ein Herz
Messgerät wie auch immer das Ding heißt
um hätte das glaube ich sagen Puls 180
der ein oder andere Minecraft Spieler
der sich wirklich mit diesem Projekt
auskennen wird sich wahrscheinlich
denken Luca
du baust gerade Steine ab I know das ist
englisch und heißt ich weiß die Sache
ist allerdings dass ich hier in
jeglicher Hinsicht Angst habe irgendein
Fehler zu machen weil ich selber weiß
dass ich nicht gut in Minecraft bin und
weil ich auch selber weiß dass das ganze
Projekt hier innerhalb von nur einer
Sache ich falsch mache vorbei sein kann
von daher meine lieben Freunde ich gehe
auf Nummer Sicher ich weiß ihr regt euch
auf aber können auf froh sein das Video
hier hat Überlänge müsste mich noch
länger ertragen ein Cobblestone hole ich
mir noch dann machen wir noch die Ecke
da hinten zu den ich weiß genau wie es
ist wenn so ein Baum in Minecraft
irgendwas droppt egal ob das ein Apfel
ist oder ob das ein Setzling ist oder so
dann lassen wir das immer so ein paar
Blöcke weit Wegfallen von daher haben
wir jetzt glaube ich genug Platz ich bau
mal das erste ab
wir brauchen einen Setzling
hinsetzen
[Musik]
immer willst du mich verarschen
das ist nicht wahr gerade
wenn ich keinen einzigen Setzlinge aus
dem Baumhaus Kriege ist dieses Projekt
vorbei weil wir nicht weiter ein Holz
rankommen
[Musik]
das ist gerade alles andere als wild
hier
das ist tendenziell sogar eher ziemlich
mild
schon wieder keinen Sinn einen Setzling
einen
einen einzigen
[Musik]
gleich wenn ich mit der anderen Hand die
damals gedrückt halten
jetzt
[Musik]
Leute wir haben ganz großes Problem wenn
das nicht so läuft dass ich hier gleich
in Setzingen raus kriege
weit weg es ist alles bisher schief
gelaufen was hat der schief gelaufen
können
es geht die Sonne auf kommt bitte bitte
einen Setzling
das war auch keiner zu boah oh mein Gott
das sieht ja wunderschön aus
ey
no joke in solchen Momenten denke ich
mir einfach nur
dieses Spiel ist
[Musik]
in stockanze fallen lassen
aber setz den geht nicht oder was jetzt
nicht so lange auf die Minecraft
Schönheit konzentrieren wir brauchen
einen verdammten Setzling sonst ist das
Projekt vorbei
ich habe mir so viel Mühe gegeben mit
dieser ganzen Plattform hier drumherum
lass mir einen Setzling
und dann haben wir vor allem selbst wenn
wir nur einen kriegen haben wir danach
wieder den struggle dass wir dann aus
dem Baum wieder einsetzen rauskriegen
müssen
[Musik]
heute
eine schätzling oh mein Gott
yes yes wir haben es wir haben es wir
können noch einen weiteren Baum pflanzen
wow oh mein Gott ich glaube ich habe
mich in Minecraft noch nie so dolle
beeilen Setzling gefreut er kriegen wir
noch einen zweiten raus nee wir haben
verdammt noch mal nur einen Eichen
Setzling bekommen ey das ist doch
wirklich nicht mehr normal einen Eichen
Setzling
haha aber gut okay wir haben in der
heutigen Folge schon die ein oder andere
Challenge hingekriegt und zwar haben wir
den Cobblestone Generator geschafft der
uns Bruchsteine liefert also ihr könnt
theoretisch hier alles voll Kleister mit
Bruchstein und wir haben unsere Insel
erweitert das beides haben wir bisher
geschafft es gibt noch 58 weitere
Aufgaben die wir in den nächsten 4 5 6
Wochen versuchen werden zu lösen zu
bewältigen bis zu Silvester von daher
wenn ihr Bock auf dieses Projekt habt
und wenn ihr Bock habt das übermorgen um
18 am Sonntag die zweite Folge von
Skyblock mit Luca online gehen soll dann
lasst einen Daumen hoch unter diesem
Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um dieses Video im
zweiten Teil von Skyblock mit Luca dann
auch nicht zu verpassen
ihr ahnt nicht wie mein Herz gerade
Punkt einen verdammten Setzling haben
wir bekommen
[Musik]